OF THE ICE AND THH
CROSS-ICE, SCHEIFELE AND
BINNINGTON NOW COMING ACROSS AND
TAKES IT, HANGING ONTO I WITH A.
TRYING THAT WRAPAROUND WITH
BINNINGTON DOWN TO THE NEG TO TF
THE NET AND THAT TIME A RIGHT
PAD SAVE IS M PASS,
A GIVE AND-AND GO AND LOOK
THERE, MI
TWO-ON-ONE FOR THE JETS AND A
WRISTER NOW, GLOVE SAVE.
HELLEBEBBINNINGTON ACROSS AND
BOZAK HERE, HE COULD NOT CLEAT
NY
INSIDE THE JETS LINE AND ONTO
THE STICKSHORT SIDE
SAVE MADE BY BINNINGTON.
[ Horn ]
THE BBONDING MOMENT
IN A WEIRD WAY AND THOSE THINGS
THAT YOU REMEMBER.
>> Dennis: WE SAW T
[ Cheering and Applause ]TEAMMAS
DOES NOT CELEBRATE FORRT,
BARBASHEV, NOT SURE IF THATALLYE
PASS WASS IN THE LAST SIX FOR H.
K
OF THE NET AS THE JETS HAVE THE.
THIS ONE, DOWN MAIN IS TEAM,
FAST TONIGHT, PRIORITY NUMBER
ONE ANDT
IN AND A CHANCE FOR DUBOIS AND H
DUBOIS, FINDING HIMSELF HERE ALL
ALONE WITH AN OPPORTUNI
[ OF THE PAD OF
BIBILON AND NOW
BACKIN AND, OH, MY
GOODNESS, CONNOR, WHAT A SAVE
PENALTY HERE THAT SHORTHANDED T,
THE JETS, THEY RESPOND!ND BOZAK,
LOOKING TO TAKE THAT SHOT AWAY
AND
CROSSBAR, UP, AND OUT OF PLAY